it feels like the whole time someone's
just going to shoot me
in the back of my head yeah that's what
it feels like walking around here but
you must feel like it is
[Music]
in this episode i along with the gang
lord explore parts of my city i never
knew existed
[Music]
hey i'm dan mace i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
[Music]
i've lived in cape town my whole life
and it feels like i've only experienced
a small portion of what the city has to
offer i've always heard stories about
areas that exist in cape town both
beautiful lesser explored neighborhoods
and dangerous gang-ridden territories my
goal in this episode is to gain access
to these places through someone
respected on both sides of the fence
both feared and loved
i am my brother hi my brother
you know what
[Music]
this is turner adams he is a reformed
notorious gang lord one of the most
dangerous gangs in the world
the numbers gang i have known him for
three years now he actually gave me this
tattoo and i've taught him how to play
the piano he seems to have continued his
then found passion for music
with me
[Music]
okay i had this idea
where i want to see cape town through a
new lens
and when i thought about who's the most
interesting person i know from cape town
it's you
and i wanted to know if you'd be my tour
guide but of course i would i would love
to
i can take you places where
[Music]
cape town by most and google is known as
this city center
beaches
forests
and while this does exist
there's a lot more to it one of those
areas known as lavender hill in the cape
flats
where approximately three people are
murdered every day with a population of
only around 670 000 people
it is 15 kilometers or 9.5 miles outside
of cape town city centre this is where
turner and his family live
i won't lie i feel
very uneasy place yeah
that is bulletproof window do you think
up there that we're one of the real
things
this is a volatile place that we walk in
if the gun shops goes up here
you won't know where to run to and you
know we've been watched by vouchers my
brother you must believe me but now they
see me with you guys we've been watched
right now yeah you've been watched
how do you mean
this is the battleground on here a lot
of
and we decided to go to the municipality
to give us this huge development
toner plans to convert what's known as
the battlefield here into a youth center
and community garden which will start to
affect real change in his community i am
really starting to see the big heart
beneath what many would describe as
terrifying and you can see all the
gardens running up and open spaces
everyone's got a guard yeah everyone's
gonna
these people want to belong to something
that gives them something constructed to
belong to them they'll take it with both
hands
[Music]
we then headed to robben island maximum
security prison which is surrounded by
the shark infested freezing cold
atlantic ocean turner served as a
prisoner here in his early 20s
[Applause]
[Music]
i like to fight you
and you'll be at peace advice every
night
yeah you're part of the number in here
yeah
okay let's get out of here
it's kind of like
to get here
[Music]
where are we going should we hit that
area
yeah let's go
turns out you're not allowed to roam
freely through the prison but we managed
to get off the island unscathed
we then headed towards a place i had no
idea existed in cape town in or rather
under an area known as district six
turner's trying to access this place
called the jungle which is the
underground tunnels
underneath cape town which
aren't used anymore apparently a
community lives in there
so he's uh
just going around and yeah finding out
if we can go down there
[Music]
they like to change places one moment
they did and this one was gone
i'm not a snake
so
[Music]
we could only access one part of the
so-called jungle the locals keep the
tunnels beneath cape town very under
wraps
but it's intriguing to know that they
are there
[Music]
should we head back
yeah we must go okay let's go lastly
turner wanted to take me to a place
which makes him feel like he's at the
edge of the world cape point the cape of
good hood which merely is it's the
second most southern tip of africa
[Music]
turner told me a fascinating story about
how the caper good hope used to be known
as the cape of storms as you can see
with the fickle weather conditions here
but for me this sums up cape town it is
the cape of good hope it has its dark
sides and history that was shown in this
video
but it has hope with people like turner
making big moves that will affect change
in his community one step at a time
so what today taught me was the
importance of micro travel i've always
been so interested in traveling outside
of my city without ever considering
finding out what hides beneath the crown
inside the areas i'd usually try and
avoid out of fear
for today
[Music]
thank you so much
[Music]
thank you to my partners at warner
brothers discovery for making the bruce
show possible four new bruce show
episodes that are unreleased on my
youtube channel just dropped on the
discovery plus streaming platform so
click on the link in the description to
watch them now and if you sign up now
you get a 14 day discovery plus promo
using the code dan mace this offer is
valid until the 25th of june 2022.
discovery plus is the home of truly
great filmmaking of truly great
storytelling and for me as a filmmaker
making films like this non-fiction based
films i rely on referencing great
content so i'd honestly say get stuck
into discovery plus now to gain access
to thousands of hours of great content
so yeah click on the link in my
description to redeem your code now and
don't forget to like subscribe share
this video
comment below letting me know that
you've done so and as always don't
forget you're awesome bruh and i'll see
you next week
[Music]